[Music]
Bennett call Saul has finally wrapped on
its fourth season similar to the season
finales that preceded it there's a lot
to unpack from the show's ending and
throughout this video I'll be discussing
episode 10 in full detail there will be
heavy spoilers so it may be worth
avoiding this video for now if you want
to watch the finale with fresh eyes
without the way I'm definition and I
ruin the show so you don't have to the
biggest take from season four is that
Jimmy McGill has finally fully adopted
the pseudonym Saul Goodman whilst he
mentioned it in the show's first season
here he is fully taken up the moniker
and is now using it as his law firm's
legal name symbolically this shows that
Jimmy is now an afterthought and the
sleazy lawyer persona that we were
introduced to in Breaking Bad is now the
face that most will see after Jimmy's
law reinstatement hearing didn't go well
because the board believed him to be
insincere the character has put some
serious time into acting as an
upstanding member of the community he
and Kim spent thousands of dollars to
create a library wing dedicated to Chuck
and Jimmy spent the best part of a year
at his brother's headstone grieving this
is all the ruse for Jimmy to get back in
the good books of the law but
unexpectedly he comes clean at a hearing
that was meant to clear his name
Jimmy was supposedly going to read a
letter from Chuck in order to pull out
the board's heartstrings but he ends up
going off script and stating that my
brother Chuck you knew him he loved me
in his own way he loved me as a brother
he did not love me as a lawyer all I
wanted to do was make him proud and he
was not an easy man to make proud he
could be a real son of a [ __ ]
chuck was the one who was always right
and he usually was for a guy like me I
did allow C in school I lacked ambition
I always cut corners for me to live up
to the standards of Charles McGill I
mean look at me I'll never be as moral
as him I'll never be as smart
I'll never be as good I'll never be as
respected I'll never be Chuck but I can
try this drives several board members to
tears and gets Jimmy reinstated where he
begins trading under the name Saul
Goodman it's not a complete win however
as Kim realizes that he delivered the
speech so convincingly that she may in
fact be in the midst of a complete
sociopath
Jimmy boasts that he completely tricked
the board into believing his story which
worries Kim massively the character
switches on a dime and we realized that
the majority of the season has been a
complete act on his behalf and that the
more sinister side of his personality
has always been driving his actions
perhaps the passing of Chuck who had
always been a moral compass released him
from the trappings he once had of
becoming an out-and-out sleazy lawyer
and his signing of Saul Goodman on the
requisite documents confirms that he's
now here to stay
similar to Saul Mike deals with a lot in
the show's final episode Werner who
built the meth lab has been perhaps
overly laxed with security throughout
the show because he was under the
impression that Mike had his back due to
this he took a 4-day leave of absence
from building the lab and also let's
slip to the Salamanca is what Gus's
overall scheme was this is unacceptable
to Gus and in the desert Mike murders
him Mike has always been the killer but
this is perhaps a step too far as he
viewed Werner as an ally at some points
but he knows that the job is of the
utmost importance we return to the meth
lab and get another huge tie-in to
Breaking Bad when we are reintroduced to
Gale Gale states that though the lab is
incomplete you will be able to work with
what they have and know we know that
things will progress there it will
always represent a failing for Gus the
lab will never truly be complete and Gus
may perhaps put blame slightly on Mike
because of it what happens after this
will be answered in season five but I'd
love to be a fly on the wall in that
place can it could look like there was
an episode with a fly from him remember
that and never mind
so what are your thoughts on season four
a better call
comment below and let me know this is a
channel for people who are mad about all
things TV movies and more so if that's
the kind of thing you like hit subscribe
make sure you check out my breakdown of
the recent Netflix show maniac I linked
at the end of this one and I just want
to give a huge shout out to Kevin Lynch
who is my channels first patreon
donations make videos like this possible
so if you'd like to help us out go to
the link in the description thanks again
for taking the time to watch this I've
been definition you've been the best and
I'll see you next time take care peace
[Music]